Continental Tire coaches corners we
bring back clay Helton how are you coach
good Dan thanks for having me little
pressure there you got to continue to
have winning record here to keep in that
group did you know that already there's
a standard of excellence that I'm
reminded every day winter road what do
you hear when you go out in the
offseason you know there's just a
reputation here and you guys see that
it's a hundred and twenty five year
tradition of excellence that's been here
and when you go out you know you're
representing something that's bigger
than yourself and you know that's the
daily message that we give our players
to that you know it has been since 2002
since you've had a losing record there
are 11 national championships here and
you know there's a standard of play that
is expected and that's why we all came
here is to uphold that standard to play
so there's an there's not an obligation
necessarily but an opportunity to
continue that tradition curious what he
thought of this Tony Romo said yesterday
once Tom Brady retires it's Aaron
Rodgers stage and Rodgers stage alone
then after that Sam Dorn 'old I tell you
what I'm proud of where Sam he's at
right now to be able to I got to watch
some of the preseason games and the one
thing that I've seen having recruiting
Sam at a high school ever watch him play
college and now you know taking that
next step to the NFL he's never changed
he's never changed his demeanor how he
goes process about preparation who he is
and I think that's what a lot of the
greats are you know they're not going to
change for other people that one of the
reason you're successful as you believe
in yourself you believe in in your
process once you do and Sam's always
been that way he has a unique poise
about him and he's got a very bright
future obviously you know there are
always growing pains when you come into
the league and there's a learning
process but he's one of those that in
the long haul will look up hopefully 15
years from now and say wow that's a
really great quarterback in 2016 before
you started your first full season as
head coach you were faced with the
dilemma at quarterback
you had redshirt junior max Brown he was
views viewed as the favored to succeed
Cody Kessler and then you had the
redshirt freshman Sam Donald XI so you
go with max Brown to start looking back
on it you know it's tough to in your
first season you're gonna roll the dice
and you're gonna put in a redshirt
freshman there in Sam Donald but looking
back giving you that hindsight there did
you make a mistake no I don't think so
I've always said that I don't regret
what we did because I made a full-speed
decision had a redshirt junior that had
played in games had experienced and we
had a pretty good team that we were
playing that first game and named
Alabama Saban and you know to put Sam in
that in that arena right off the bat I
didn't think was the right time I wanted
to be able to make sure he got playing
time so he wasn't ready no he was in a
position he was in a position that he
had had a great camp but you never know
until you walk in and actually play a
game and he had not yet would the other
young man max had and and had done well
and had played really well in camp and
so you make a full-speed decision and
what you thought was best in a moment
for your team and in that moment and my
whole heart was max Brown and you know
wish we would have been wish we would
have won three games straight but we
didn't we were one and two and the ball
wasn't moving very well and Sam had
played in the first three games you can
see that he didn't get big eyed the
stage wasn't too big that he played just
like he had practiced and at that time
you go okay it's time to make the move
here how often do you hear from parents
about playing time for their kids very
often how do they get ahold of you well
you know one of the things that you know
I've always believed when you're dealing
with 18 to 21 year olds is is so
important to keep relationships not only
with the with the players but also with
the parents you know I've always said
I've got three children by birth and
I've got a hundred and ten sons I got
the honor to adopt and when when a
family basically entrust you with their
son you just don't stop that
relationship you know you communicate
with them and say hey this is where he's
at these are strengths these are his
areas of growth I don't like to use
weakness but these are his areas of
growth and you know we're gonna continue
to develop him and when he's the best
player he'll step on the field that's
the beauty of college football there's
no politics because if you don't win
they they find new coaches in a hurry at
this level so but you communicate that
with them I think that's one of the
biggest things you have to do as a coach
is communicate with your players let
them know where they're standing this
the parents have questions that you take
the time to in the consideration to be
able to have a conversation with them
he's clay Helton USC head coach UNLV is
the first team on their schedule joining
us Dan Patrick show
giving your coaching logic of why you
didn't start Sam Donald that you were
going into a big game neutral site with
Alabama JT Daniels is a true freshman
but you're gonna roll the dice on him if
you were facing Alabama or Clemson or
Alban or someone you know it's a top
five team would what JT Daniels be
starting this first game yeah different
situation intense totally because in
this situation at three young men that
had no playing experience Matt was the
only one and extremely limited I think
in in games and you know so when we
walked into this dis competition as a
staff we said okay we need to go with a
guy that is performing the best
especially in scrimmage situations live
ball situations how is the ball being
moved how is it putting who's putting it
in the end zone and in this in this
situation really felt that we walked out
of camp JT was doing that the best we
did not have a wrestler jr. we didn't
have a guy that had played in in a lot
of games we had three young men that it
would be basically their first time to
lead a football team so in that
situation we said okay we've got to go
with who is producing the best in camp
and JT was ahead of the other two
what'd she do better at this stage than
Sam darn 'old you know but I would say
both had a unique sense of being able to
pull the trigger
you know usually with young people when
they first come in to college football
there's the guys that want to see things
open or guys that the row the receiver
open they see a window and they pull the
trigger to be able to put the ball there
on time and JT and Sam both had that
have that as a very very young age I
have been really impressed with JT's
deep ball accuracy in the moment we go
walk in the Coliseum for the first time
and you know he acts like he's been
there a hundred times and that poise
that he had to be able to make big plays
down the field at such an early age when
he's competing to be the starting
quarterback at USC in the Coliseum was
extremely impressive for that age but
both kids both kids at a very young age
could pull the trigger and that's what
stands out to me as a father you know we
learned the hard way about having
patience but you have all of these kids
and you have to have patience and then
you have 18 year olds that you know
you're pinning your coaching future on I
mean it's crazy when you think about it
that they're so young and they give in
these big moments and you know there's
only so much you can do as a coach
father figure here how many times do you
have to be reminded to have patience
very often that's why that's why I don't
get a lot of sleep at night I've lost
over the hair but you know I've had the
good fortune of one playing the position
and coaching the position and I know
that a large part of it isn't when you
make a decision support that decision
you know and give that young man the
opportunity to show himself improve
himself and know that when you're 18
years old there's going to be mistakes
it's not going to be perfect that you're
gonna hit bumps in the road and I think
it's really important when you're
playing a young quarterback that you
tell the rest of the team hey guys we
have to be able to supportive of this
guy we have to play great defense we
have to play great special teams
the best friend of a quarterback is a
running game we have to be able to
establish a establish the run we have to
play great team football and then
realize he's gonna make mistakes correct
those mistakes a good thing with JT is
usually when he makes a mistake and he
teach him he has not made it again and
that's what you hope from your
quarterback your players ever ask you
how good you were as a player that would
they talk about I was not very good I'm
a lot better coach sitting I have a
player but now they know I played
quarterback played for dad that dad
comes around each camp and hangs out
with us and they know matter of fact I
think they had a subclips of me playing
in the Coliseum when I was with dad my
last year in college and getting getting
my bus damn Google I can always come
back and hunch
oh yeah no quit no questions they were
like coach we thought you were a lot
better do as I say not as I did exactly
right
hey good to visit with you we'll check
in during the season and have fun
against UNLV Thank You coach thanks Dan
take care that's a clay Helton UNC
football coach for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]